I've been a political cartoonist on the
global stage for the last 20 years a we
have seen a lot of things happen in
those 20 years we saw three different
Catholic popes and we witness that
unique moment the election of a pope on
st. Peter's Square you know the little
white smoke and the official
announcement
we saw four American presidents Obama of
course Oh
Europeans liked him a lot he was a
multilateral list he favored diplomacy
you wanted to be friends with Iran
and then reality imitated caricature the
day Don ultram became the President of
the United States of America
you know people come to us and they say
it's too easy for you cartoonist I mean
with people like [ __ ] well no it's not
easy to caricature a man who is himself
a caricature no populist are no easy
target for satire because you try to
nail them down one day and the next day
they outdo you for example as soon as
soon as he was elected I try to imagine
the treat that Trump would send on on
Christmas Eve so I did this okay and
basically the next day basically the
next day Trump tweeted this
it's the same
this this is the era of strongmen and
soon Donald Trump was able to meet his
personal hero Vladimir Putin and this is
this is how the first meeting went I'm
not inventing anything he came out of
that first meeting saying that the two
of them had agreed on a joint task force
on cybersecurity this is true if you do
remember oh who would have imagined the
things we saw over these 20 years we saw
Great Britain ran towards a European
Union exits
in the Middle East we believed for a
while in the Democratic miracle of the
Arab Spring we saw dictators fall we saw
others hang on and then there is the
timeless Kim dynasty of North Korea
these guys seem to be coming straight
out of Cartoon Network I was I was
blessed to be able to draw two of them
Kim jong-il the father when he died a
few years ago that was a very dangerous
moment
that was
and then the Sun gives alone proved
himself a worthy successor to the throne
he's now friend with the US president
they meet each other all the time and
they talk like friends should we be
surprised to be living in a world ruled
by egomaniacs what if they were just a
reflection of ourselves I mean look at
us each of us yeah we love our
smartphones we love our selfies we love
ourselves and thanks to Facebook we have
a lot of friends all over the world Mark
Zuckerberg is our friend
you know he and his peers
in Silicon Valley are the kings and the
emperors of our time showing that the
Emperor's are no clothes has no clothes
that's the task of satire right speaking
truth to power this has always been the
historical role of political cartooning
in the 1830s post revolution France
under King louis-philippe journalists
and caricature is fought hard for the
freedom of the press
they were jailed they were fine with it
but they prevailed and this caricature
of the king by dummy came to define the
monarch it marked history it became the
timeless symbol of satire triumphing
over autocracy today 200 years after
domi our political cartoons at risk of
disappearing see this blank space on the
front page of Turkish opposition
newspapers shown or yet this is where
Musa cards cartoon used to appear in
2018 music art was sentenced to three
years in jail for doing what for doing
political cartoons in arrogance Turkey
cartoonists from Venezuela Russia Syria
have been forced into exile look at this
image
it seems so innocent right yet it is so
provocative when he posted this image
honey Abbas knew it would change his
life it was in 2012 and the Syrians were
taking to the street of course the
little red flower is the symbol of the
Syrian Revolution so pretty soon the
regime was after him and he had to flee
the country a good friend of his
cartoonist Akram Ruslan didn't make it
out of Syria he died under torture in
the United States of America recently
some of the very top cartoonists like
Nick Anderson and Rob Rogers this is a
cartoon by Rob
they lost their positions because their
publishers found their work too critical
of Trump and the same happened to
Canadian colonies Mitel the other a
maybe we should start worrying political
cartoons were born with democracy and
they are challenged when freedom is you
know over the years with the cartooning
for Peace Foundation and other
initiatives Kofi Annan this is not well
known he was the honorary chair of our
foundation the late Kofi Annan Nobel
Peace Laureate he was a great defender
of cartoons or on the board of the
Association of American editorial
cartoonists we have advocated on behalf
of jail threatened fired
exiled cartoonist but I never saw a case
of someone losing his job over a cartoon
he didn't do well that happened to me
for the last 20 years I have been with
the International Herald Tribune and the
New York Times then something happened
in April 2000 19 a cartoon by a famous
Portuguese called mist which was first
published in newspaper let's fresco in
Lisbon was picked by an editor at the
New York Times and reprinted in the
International editions this thing blew
up
it was denounced as anti-semitic
triggered widespread outrage apologies
and a lot of damage control by the times
a month after my editor told me they
were ending political cartoons all
together so we could and we should have
a discussion about the curtain some
people say it reminds them of the wars
anti-semitic propaganda others including
in Israel say though it's just a harsh
criticism of Trump who's shown as
blindly following the Prime Minister of
Israel I have some issues with this
curtain but that discussion did not
happen at the New York Times under
attack they took the easiest path
in order to not have problems with
political cartoons in the future let's
not have any at all hey this is new
did we just invent preventive
self-censorship I think this is bigger
than cultures this is about opinion and
journalism this Indian is about
democracy we now live in a world where
moralistic mobs gather on social media
and rise like a storm the most
outrageous voices tend to define the
conversation and the angry crowd follows
in these social media mobs sometimes
fueled by interest group fall upon
newsrooms in an overwhelming blow they
send publishers and editors scrambling
for countermeasures this leaves no room
for meaningful discussions Twitter is a
place for fury not for the dead you know
what someone described pretty well our
human condition in this noisy age you
know who Shakespeare 400 years ago this
speaks to me Shakespeare is still very
relevant no but the world has changed a
bit
it's true
now social media is both a blessing and
a curse for cartoons this is the era of
the image so they get shared the get
viral but that also makes them prime
targets more than often the real target
behind the cartoon is the media that
published it that relationship between
traditional media and social media is a
21 on one hand you have the
time-consuming process of information
verification curation on the other hand
it's an open design frankly for rumours
opinions emotions amplified by
algorithms even quality newspapers mimic
the codes of social networks on their
website they highlight the 10 most read
the 10 most shared stories they should
put forward the 10 most important
stories
the media must not be intimidated by
social media and editors should stop
being afraid of the angry mob we're not
gonna put up warnings the way we do on
cigarette packs are we come on
political cartoons are meant to provoke
just like opinions but before all they
are meant to be thought-provoking you
feel hurt just let it go you don't like
it look the other way
freedom of expression is not
incompatible with dialogue and listening
to each other but it is incompatible
with intolerance
let us not become our own sensors in the
nave in the name of political
correctness we need to stand up we need
to push back because if we don't we will
wake up tomorrow in a sanitized world
where any form of satire and political
cartooning becomes impossible because
politics when political pressure meets
political correctness freedom of speech
perishes
do you remember January 2015 with the
massacre of journalists and cartoonists
actually in Paris we discovered the most
extreme form of censorship murder
remember how it felt
whatever one thought of that satirical
magazine however one felt about those
particular cultures we all sensed that
something fundamental was at stake that
citizens of free societies actually
citizens of any society need humor as
much as the air we breathe this is why
the extremists you know the the
dictators the autocrats and frankly all
the ideologues of the world cannot stand
humor in the insane world we live in
right now we need political cartoons
more than ever and we need humor
[Applause]
[Music]